vous aurez des mettre la main sur le
colis et nous le livre 1 a dû s'adapter
et j'ai une tête d'abruti oui non comme
on dit pendant la guerre les nazis ont
volé une fortune en lingots d'or à la
france les habitants ont inondé le
village pour les arrêter aujourd'hui
tout repose au fond du lac
on parle d'une opération totalement
illégal en plein coeur d'un périmètre et
demi
il semblerait qu'un nombre de chasseurs
de primes serbe soit à l'affût pour
voulu quitter
on se bat pas la loi
est ce que vous aviez conscience de
bafouer votre serment d'allégeance
j'ai toujours su que ma mort fera du
bruit
ça va tomber
j'ai peut-être pas choisi le bon caleçon
on a un char droite pendant ta deuxième
derrière nous va se baigner les gars ans